مره في الاستديو الفنانين جميله شذى حسون
يسعد صباحك يا شذى شكرا على تواجدك معانا
نورتي الاستوديو شكرا جزيلا شكرا على هذه
الاستضافه الجميله وسعيده اكون وياكم
اليوم احلى اسعد مبارك لك هالنجاح المبهر
للاغنيه بعد اطلاقها بيوم واحد فقط
مونامور مع الشاب فوده تحيه له شكرا جزيلا
وسعيده جدا بهذه الاغنيه وهذا اول مره
اقدم هذا الستايل
من الاغاني من خلال
التواجد مع الفنان جميل يعني اريد اوجه
لها تحيه كبيره همم سعيده بالضيوف جميل
جدا همم لكل الوطن العربيه صارت كان في
اكثر من بلد
لان اتصور ما متعودين علي هوايه بهذا
الستايل الحمد لله في همم يعني همم نجاح
جميل مش متعودين عليك بهذه الستايل ستايل
كان روحي كثير جميله وحلوه وكان اول ديو
في 2000 و23 كيف كانت تجربتك بهالستاهل
جديد بالاغنيه المغربيه
هذه مو اول مره اقدم الاغنيه المغربيه
يعني يعني سبق وقدمت يعني اكثر من اغنيه
مغربيه من بداياتي الى اليوم بس طبعا لهجه
صعبه مش سهله على الكل ايه طبعا يعني
مغربيه الكل يعرف يعني
والدتي مغربيه والوالده عراقي فاللهجه
المغربيه عندي سهله جدا وبسيطه
حبيت انه يكون
اكو شيء جديد يعني اقدمه وصار هذا التعامل
مع فوديل مع انه الاغنيه صار لها ثلاث
سنوات
ونصف هتصورها هسه صار الوقت المناسبه
الكلاب
جدا حبينا شويه نواكب باليوم همم لده يصير
على همم السوشيال ميديا
وحبينا نقدم شباب جديد فريش
كلمه مونامور على مود ناس يعني ما يعرفوني
بمعنى حبيبي اللي هي كلمه فرنسيه
نقدم في هذا الشيء جد المغرب العربي طيب
نبارك لك ذلك تكريمه كان في فداء الامس
حدثيني اكثر عن هذا الفكري تكريم مهرجان
كيال ومنرجع
طويل يعني
دائما ما يكون اكو حضور كبير من نجوم من
العراق سعيده انه البارحه قدمنا الاغنيه
لاول مره انا وفضل وكذلك تم تكريمي وهمم
وسعيده يعني جدا نلتقي بكميه من الفنانين
الاصدقاء جدا على قلبي وهمم وكذلك الاعلام
يعني كانت همم يعني اكسبيريا بس حلوه لبعض
استاذه وصوتها الجميل اهل شنو حابه تتحفنا
في الاستديو اي شيء منك حلو بنسمع
اوكي
هالعيون ودادا
محلاها نهار العيد
بالكراده انا كرهانه
يا عليا بابا
مامي غريب مايا حنين بلاده
على صوتك
[موسيقى]
اعمال من خلال البوم الان قاعده اجهز لك
باكثر من اللهجه راح تسمعوني في
لهجه اللبنانيه اللهجه المصريه لاول مره
اللهجه الخليجيه من انتاج لايف ستايل
ستوديوس
ويعني همم حيكون اعمال ان شاء الله مكثف
الفتره القادمه
خلال الفتره الاخيره
واسمك في كل مواقع التواصل عشان في شاب في
العراق قام بتقبيل قدمك يعني شو توضح لنا
هذا الموقف خصوصا انه البعض حمل لكن
مسؤوليه على شو بترد عليه والله شلونك
[موسيقى]
افعال المحبين او الفائز ما نقدر همم
اي انسان يحب فنك يحب شخصك ممكن كل واحد
يجيب طريقته وحقيقه هذا من همم من الفانز
القديمين يعني ودائما همم
يدعم يدعمني يدعمني في السوشل ميديا وصار
له الفتره دائما يبعث للقريبين مني لاداره
اعمال لانه حابب يلتقي بيه
فصارت انه همم كنت في بغداد وهمم الثقه بي
وصار اللي صار ههه
[موسيقى]
همم
اصدقاء انا واخواننا من الخليج العربي همم
شفت سعاده عامه من العراقيين الاستقبالهم
همم
تم يوم بمحبه كبيره جدا من كل بصره
ومن كل عراقي انت مثل ما شفتوا الافتتاح
كان ضخم كبير جدا وانا سعيده يعني جدا
لانه حقيقه انا كذلك من الناس اللي اليوم
همم يعني بدي اشتغل بكل جهدي انه اقدم
العراق وبغداد بطريقه جديده وبطريقه
عالميه وعربيه من خلال ان شاء الله اعمال
ومهرجانات راح تشوفوها قريبا جدا من
تنظيمي ومن تنظيم شركاتتي
كذلك جمهورك مشاريعك المستقبل
عندي اغاني اكثر من لهجات راح اقدمها ان
شاء الله راح تشوفوني
يعني باكله ان شاء الله للحفلات
والمرجانات
نشتغل كذلك مثل ما قلت في بغداد وفي اكثر
من محافظه على احياء الفن
الوضع الفني بالعراق ان شاء الله
وهتشوفوا مفاجات قريبا جدا باذن الله شكرا
جزيلا لك يعني شو اخر سؤال بس شو الاغنيه
الاقرب لشذى سمعنا كهرمانه نعرف روح
الساعه البنت تحبيني
شو في اول اغنيه قدمتها فاكيد اول اغنيه
دائما تكون تعلق فيها بس حقيقه مثل ما
يقولون كلهم اولادي
بس كلهم حقيقه ان شاء الله اللي هتسمعه
همم بالفتره القادمه هيكون اجمل باذن الله
الفنانه الجميله